- Yeah, I don't wanna get
near that heat and
alienate anybody out there.
And that's why Judy and Zainab are here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Judy Gold
and Zainab Johnson.
(audience cheers)
- Hallo.
- Hi.
I love you both so much.
I'm so happy
we get to do this.
- I love it.
- This is so fun.
All right.
You're gonna give us your
takes on these news topics.
And the first one is, this week's
miss manners and the Washington
post answered a letter
from a person upset
that their friend never likes
their social media posts.
And now they're thinking
of not liking their friends post back.
Warm topic.
Zainab.
What do you think?
Do you have to like your
friend's post or not?
- Absolutely like your friend's post.
We have to choose our battles in life
and social media should
never be one of them.
It doesn't matter if the picture
is bad, you don't like it.
Like it, heart it, love it.
It's your friend.
- Right.
It takes, it's no sweat
to do something like that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I can see that.
Well, Judy, what about you?
- Oh please.
Okay.
You cannot.
You cannot, first of all,
half of my friends' posts
are full of crappola.
Like you cannot live up to the life
that you present on social media.
They act like they're perfect marriage
and everything's fantastic.
And meanwhile, they're
all calling me like,
I can't take it anymore.
I gotta get out of this relationship.
So I can't, I don't know.
I can't lie.
I feel like friendship without
honesty is not friendship.
So,
- Oh my God, Judy, I love you.
And that is exactly why we
look to you for these things.
Okay.
Next step.
New study from Boise
state university finds
that a man who holds a cat
in his dating profile is
like perceived less datable
for women, even though
generally pet owners are seen
as more datable.
Warm topic.
Zainab, cats.
No, go for dating?
- No.
No to the cat man.
No, no no,
No Judy.
No to the cat man.
- What?
- First of all,
- If he has a cat, he's
dating the cat Judy.
No to the cat.
Cats are territorial.
They scratch stuff.
No, I wanna be the only
one hissing in the house.
- Alright.
I, by the way, I love a good hiss.
Judy thoughts.
(Judy hisses)
- Okay.
So, I would, this is what I think.
All right.
I'm a lesbian.
So I know a lot about felines.
Okay?
So I,
am thinking as if I,
it shows that the guy
likes to stay at home and cuddle.
He's fine with cleaning cat litter
which means he'll change the diapers.
Okay?
And he's secure enough
that he doesn't have to go
outside with this big man dog.
So I think,
it says
that he's sensitive and,
and sort of a home body.
And I don't know.
I think it's a good thing.
But who, what do I know?
- I have to say too
like when you get older,
you start ticking things
off the list that you were,
you know, picky about before.
You're like, "Are you nice?
"And I don't care if you have cats."
So anyway, last topic.
The latest new Yorker reported
on an artist who takes photos
of strangers, text messages,
while they're not looking.
It's a little voyeuristic
window into their private lives.
Judy, is it okay to be a
cell phone snooper or not?
- No, I'm not into that.
Like, I have so much drama in
my own life that I don't want.
I can't even look at my own texts.
I don't wanna look at other
people's texts, you know?
And I think, well, unless
it's like a casting director
or your ex don't look
at other people's texts.
- Zainab thoughts.
- You know, honestly, drew, I thought
that we were supposed to be
maintaining six feet distance.
So I don't know how you would
see someone's text anyway.
- Zainab,
- Nice.
as I say to Frankie all
the time, which is a quote
from a cartoon, a touché pussy cat.
Absolutely.
(upbeat music)